λίψειως φαρμάκων που επηριαζεί πολύ και τ τη χώρα μας έχουμε ένα επριπαϊκό σχέδιον καταπολέμησης
του καρκίνου που τρέχει και δεν τελειώνει τέλος του χρόνουμε τα συμβληλωθεί η δηθική μουθητία
πότε υπηλώνες και θα έλεγα τα θεμέλεια για την ευρωπαϊκή ενωσιηείας είναι εκεί ποιο σημαντικόμως
είναι και τότι άλλα ξε οι αντίλιψη που υπάρχει γύρου από τη θέματα εγείας στα
κράτη μέλιστης κυβερνήσεις και στους πολίτης και οι πολίτες περιμένουν από μας περισσότερα σε ευρωπαικό
επίπεδο για την ιγεία και πιστέποτη και ο επόμενος ε ευρωπαίος επίτροπος θα συνεχίσει στο
ίδιο πλέύμα λόγω για της κατάστασης τόσο στην ουκρανία και τώρα στο λύβανο εσεας πι
είναι η εμπλοκή σας σε όλα αυτό ή στην αποστολή φαρμάκων είτε με τους ασθενης
είναι ένα χαρτοφυλάκιο που δεν μπορώ να σας πω ότι υπάρχει μέρα που δεν δεν
πρέπει να είσαι σε γρήγορση η από την ισβολτηση στη ρηςτης ρωσίες την οκρανία εγώ
είχαμε ταβεί στην ουκρανία των ιούλιον οκοίνου του χρόν και έχο μια εξαρετική συνεργασία με
των υπουργό ηγίας της ουκρανίας έχουμε πρόχωρήσεις στων πορέσουμε να νοσηλευτού έναστερά στιος αριθμός ασθενών
σε αλλά σε ευρωπαϊκακρατημέλι σε θέματα αποκατάσταση σε θέματα φαρμάκων το ίδιον προχωρήσαμε τώρα και
με θέμαν που υπάρχει στην κς παζί με των συνάδελφο επίτροπο λέναρξη και έχουμε να
από στίλ ίδη επιστολέσεις στα κράτημέλη για να μπορούν να δεχθούν ασθενείς από την κάς
είναι μια πρωτοβουλία που τρέχει ώστε να μπορούμε να ενισχύσουμε και να αντιμετωπίσουμε αυτές τους
αυτός τους πολέμους που έχουν μια αντεράστι αδιάσταση στα θέματα ηγείας πω